نزع صوره فينيسيوس من محيط ملعب ريال
مدريد جوردي البا ثاني الراحلين عن
برشلونه
يوفنتوس يخسر النجومه بسبب الاتحاد
الاوروبي
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
لا تزال قضيه فينيسيوس جونيور طاغيه على
المشهد الرياضي في اسبانيا وعلى مواقع
التواصل تم تداول صوره تظهر نزعه وجه
فينيسيوس من بوستر في ملعب في محيط ملعب
سانتياغو برنابيو ويرجح المتابعون بان هذا
الفعل هو من طرف مشجعي اتلتيكو مدريد خاصه
بعد التهديد الذي قاموا به سابقا بشنق
دميه تحمل قميص فيني على احد جسور العاصمه
مدريد
من جهه قرر نادي فالنسيا الاسباني
الاستئناف ضد قرار الاتحاد المحلي بغلق
جزء من مدرجات الملعب ووصف احد المصادر
داخل نادي لوكاله الانباء الاسبانيه وصف
هذا العقوبه بالظالمه مضيفا بان نادي يدرس
جميع الخيارات المتاحه امامه بمواجهه هذه
العقوبه كما دعت اداره فالنسيا الاحترام
النادي وعدم وصف جماهيره بالعنصريه
في كتالونيا اعلن برشلونه رحله جوردي البا
قبل موسم واحد من نهايه عقده مع النادي
ليكون ثاني المغادرين بعد سيرجيو بوسكيت
البخاخه مع البلوغرانا 458 مباراه وتوجع
مع نادي بتسعه عشره لقبا كما يعد البا
واحدا من اللاعبين الذين تخرجوا من
اكاديميه
الخاصه ببرشلونه
وبعد الاخبار التي تفيد بنيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي معاقبه يوفنتوس الايطالي بسبب
مخالفات تتعلق باللعب الرياضي النظيف اصبح
البيان كونيري مهددا من فقدان نجومه حيث
تتضمن العقوبه حرمانه من اللعب اوروبيا
وهو الامر الذي سيجبر اداره النادي على
الاستماع للعروض المقدمه للاعبين وفي
مقدمتهم الثنائي
لكن ورغم هذا سيكون من الصعب تحقيق امنيه
الكثير من مشجعي السيده العجوز ويتخلص من
المدرب اليغري بسبب الشرط الجزائي العالي
في عقده
[موسيقى]